foreign
you're cool to just wait here for animal
control
Animal Control
I've been controlling animals since I
was six
cool okay
I'm gonna go home and lie down
draw the shades there's
sun in here
by Dwight
goodbye Jim
and good luck
Jim is on a path now
an eternal Journey
and I wish him well
but I have a destiny in this realm
specifically
in the kitchen
and it's all from the same series oh
called Impressions oh
not that I would call myself an
impressionist per se
but maybe one day
I hope so
I still need you know my breakthrough or
whatever
hey babe how are you good
hi brother brother huh hey Kenny hey Pam
hey uh
how about this hi
I showed my brother and no one from work
is here
that's pretty cool huh
magic time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
my God
you're welcome
so you're probably wondering about the
snake yeah I'm wondering about the
fuckest thing that's exactly what I'm
wondering about Jillian G it's all
completely above board the State of
Florida pays me to do this job check it
out I've got a pamphlet
ten years ago there was a trend for
people to get Burmese pythons as pets
they start out really cute that can't be
true it is but then they got too big so
everyone drove their snakes out to the
swamps and set them free but they're not
from here so nothing eats them but they
eat everything Birds okay alligators
even other snakes it's an ecological
disaster so the state pays a removal
agents a hundred bucks for every dead
python we bring in it's a quick and easy
way to earn some extra cash it didn't
seem easy they're not poisonous they're
really slow they're like big hot dogs
that can bite you or squeeze you to
death but also
they can kind of smile you know this has
been very informative and all that but
you think we hey hey it's the love you
Kelly
okay okay
[Music]
oh
Merry Christmas
no why why did you bring that here don't
worry she's dead oh wait
he's dead why what
I accidentally ran over it it's a
Christmas miracle well get it out of
here relax okay and because this is
Christmas I am going to roast this goose
and prepare it with a wild rice dressing
do we have any cayenne pepper in the
kitchen
Merry Christmas Dwight Jim wow what we
got here what does it look like
dead goose and circle gets the square
right
so can you watch this I'm gonna get my
carving knife out of the trunk uh why
are we thought about this no Toby this
is different he's already dead
once I brought in a duck to prepare for
lunch
and people got upset
apparently they got attached to the duck
and didn't want to see it killed he was
already dead and we shrutes use every
part of the goose the meat has a
delicious Smoky rich flavor plus you can
use the molten goose grease and save it
in the refrigerator thus saving you a
trip to the store for a can of expensive
goose grease wow win-win exactly thank
you Jim I like goose and it's already
dead is it so crazy if we eat it that's
crazy it's crazy no
that's why you cannot keep that here
okay that is ridiculous and totally
against the spirit of Christmas
come on Dwight
we went over this light for a half an
hour
dead animal in our office
sorry
clean it in your car
I would like it off my desk
I just didn't think every relationship
that starts with a lie is bad we never
would have become Partners if I hadn't
pretended I drove a Mercedes yet here we
are trapping through the swamp
empty-handed Drew's still out on where
this is headed
[Music]
please help what happened
oh my God it's going all the way around
oh yeah
why are you gonna throw
[ __ ] hot in there I'll be naked but
the suit shakes my penis
the suit you just put a hole in by the
way thanks for that oh sorry for saving
your life yeah he didn't save my life
you ruined my take I was pretending to
be strangled build tension for the video
that's right Hot Shot smile cause you're
on camera
are you [ __ ] serious
where's the camera Corby what I I
dropped it I got scared did I call cut
you weren't breathing God damn
that is method acting son you've done
enough these to know that's part of our
process uh it looks like you've paid
yourself
that's your snake pee
the snake peed on top of my penis when
he got scared so I don't talk I'm sorry
we ruined your video here you go we'll
just be taking our snake yeah I'll tell
you well it's my snake but we healed it
yeah well I could have killed it anytime
I want to but if I killed too easily
there's no story and I'm a [ __ ]
Storyteller so sorry tough [ __ ] my snake
[ __ ] it look we'll turn it in together
and split it all right just put some
clothes on clean the pee off yourself
all right are you feeling better hello
oh you're the cutest button
worked up quite a swag
s right now concerning them to the lab
I am a farmer Angela what does that mean
okay when a farmer sees an animal that
is in pain that has no quality of life
that has no utility a farmer does what
city Folk don't have the stomach to do
you didn't kill her I I sang her her
favorite songs
it was beautiful and gentle and
respectful I fed her antihistamines and
she gradually fell asleep well then she
barf them up in the freezer and tried to
get out well I'm not responsible for
that Hey ow
it's okay nothing I'm robbing her it's
nothing it's fine what
to do that without telling me I thought
I was helping you I expected a hug I
took care of that cat the best way I
knew how
cat Heaven is a beautiful place but you
don't get there if you're euthanized I
know a great taxidermist I'll pay to
have her stuffed well he's not great but
he's pretty good